hey vsauce michael here and i'm sure
that we all love to have
fun with hand shadows but how much
does a shadow weigh it might sound like
a silly question
because it is i mean a shadow cannot be
put on a scale
and weighed but the material that it
falls on top of
can be weighed and we know that light
has
energy in fact when light encounters an
object
it pushes that object just a little bit
on the surface of earth when sunlight is
hitting it
every square inch is being pushed with a
force of about a
billionth of a pound which
is basically nothing but over a large
enough surface area the results can be
pretty fun
on a sunny day the city of chicago
weighs
300 pounds more simply because sunlight
is falling on it
pushing it in outer space where solar
wind isn't filtered by earth's
atmosphere or magnetic field
the results are even bigger a spacecraft
traveling from
earth to mars would be pushed by
light 1000 kilometers off course
so these things have to be factored into
journeys to mars
we've actually already created things
that can sail
with light giant reflective solar sails
that are
pushed by the sun's light so in a way
that is calculatable
though difficult to measure an area
covered in
shadow technically weighs less than
surrounding areas
being pushed by light but enough about
the sun
there are three astronomical bodies that
can cast
shadows on the surface of earth bright
enough for us humans to see
one is obviously the sun and the other
is the moon
but what's the third
venus pete lawrence investigated this
over at digital sky
now to make sure that the shadow he saw
was caused by venus
he used a tube that could be pointed at
specific regions in the sky
inside the tube he put a cutout shaped
like the astronomical symbol for venus
now here is light coming through the
tube when pointed
just adjacent to venus at a point in the
sky
relatively dark and empty to the human
eye
but here is what came out of the tube
when pointed
at venus a venusian shadow
we all know that light travels quickly
299 million
792 458 meters
per second c but
this light right here in fact the light
coming off of your screen into your
eyeballs right now
is moving slightly slower than c
because c is the speed of light in a
vacuum
but all of this light is having to
travel through a medium
in this case air the speed of light in
air
is ever so slightly slower than c
298 925 574
meters per second this is
interesting because light travels more
slowly through different materials
but c remains the universal speed limit
and as long as an object doesn't go that
fast it can still
outpace light in a material
a charged particle for instance an
electron
can travel through water faster than
light does
but never faster than c when this
happens
we get something analogous to a sonic
boom
we get a photonic boom in a sonic boom
the sound information propagating off of
the object
is in the form of compression waves and
as the object gets closer and closer to
the speed of
sound the speed that those waves are
moving away from it at
each new wave has less time to get out
of the way of the next
until eventually the waves collapse all
into each other and the density
and pressure is enormous causing a sonic
boom
normally when a charged particle moves
through a material whose molecules can
be polarized
the molecules give off photons but each
photon has
room to fly away and the waves
all destructively interfere with each
other so no radiation is given off
but the faster the particle goes the
less
room the photons have away from each
other and their waves begin to
constructively interfere
giving off a photonic boom cherenkov
radiation
astronauts especially those who have
gone all the way to the moon
have reported seeing flashes of light
many people attribute this
to high speed particles moving through
the liquid
inside their eye faster than light
normally would
causing photonic booms right inside
their body
speaking of the speed of light here's a
great question a few of you have sent me
it involves a possible way of going
faster than c here's how it goes
let's say i want to push a button that
is a light year away from me
which means that it would take light the
fastest possible thing in the universe
a year just to get from me to the button
okay
well what if i built a board one light
year long
all the way from me to the button and
then i
pushed one end of the board would the
other end
immediately push the button and if so
did i just break the speed of light
did i just send information faster than
light
well we're not talking about the speed
of light anymore are we
we are talking about the speed of
push when you push a rigid object
what you are really doing is putting a
series of compression
waves through the object which move at
the speed
of sound in the object's material
the information about whoa we've been
pushed you should move
is sent via that compression wave and it
only travels at the speed of
sound so when pushing a normal
day-to-day size type object it feels
almost instantaneous but when pushing a
light-year-long
board it would take a lot longer a cool
way to see this in action is to look at
an object in which compression waves
travel more
slowly for instance what veritasium has
done
blowing mines by showing slinkies
being dropped the information telling
the slinky that
hey we're moving travels through the
slinky slow enough that a slow-mo camera
can see it happen
if you haven't watched all of
veritasium's slinky videos
you've missed out in fact you should
watch all of their stuff
it is superb but to wrap things up
here's the point
the speed of push is not
instant and it's certainly not the speed
of light
but light can push
you in fact technically you weigh
more when the lights are on than you do
when the lights
are off i've put links in the
description to all kinds of cool things
you should definitely check out for fun
and for science and as always thanks for
watching